I mean I did for a while I did a bunch
of those
um like Saturday morning kids shows like
um those Saved by the Bell type of
things that were I don't remember the
names of all of them but I did a guest
stars on a bunch of those
but it was probably within the year or
two that I got American Pie now was
American Pie the same sort of thing
where you go I'm gonna go in with an
accent I'm gonna think they I want them
to think I talk like this
no no I
I don't remember exactly what I did but
I do remember that the casting director
came over to me and he's like look I'm
going to call you back for the directors
but you got to work on your accent
because I mean look I'm not saying this
he said this I don't know if it's not PC
but he is like try not to sound deaf
because that's how I sounded doing the
accent to him that's what he said to you
so you went home and you go well how do
I not okay
and you just worked on
um yeah I I don't I don't remember how I
worked on it after that I think I worked
with a few different dialect coaches
um I just don't remember at what point
how much time did you have to prepare
the second time around
I don't remember just not not a long
time you had to work fast
yeah is it something you could just jump
into like you jumped into the Russian
can you just jump into that accent now
I mean it's the same accent pretty much
is it pretty much the same
it was Czechoslovakian so yeah it was I
pretty much did the same accent but like
what had happened I was in an acting
class and so you you know Joe my ex yes
okay are you guys still friendly are you
still friendly he's he's actually
managing me he's helping manage me while
I'm here so yeah beautiful what a rarity
what a rare thing in Hollywood an
ex-husband manages his ex-wife good for
you guys
yeah that's good man because I know it
wasn't easy in the beginning after the
breakup it was like there's a lot of
distance for a while
for two years for two years
yeah and then we found our way back to
being friends and and now like we we
help each other so yeah it's beautiful
no he's a great guy
um but he he and I were in an acting
class together and there at one point
there was a scene I was trying to do
from Pulp Fiction and I was trying to do
French and I can't do a French accent
and he said remember we're in class when
you tried to do French do that accent
because it sounded Russian like oh okay
it's just one of those accents that is
easier for me like everybody has an
accent that they can just like fake I
guess and for some reason that's just
one of them that I could sort of do but
with that said when I when I did
American Pie
um they called me in to do ADR which is
all the voice of her stuff after after
you've filmed and they're like we're
gonna play with the accent a bit and so
I'd say something and they're like okay
now do less of an accent and I'd say it
again they're like do less
I'm like why why are they messing with
this accent so much because I had worked
really hard with like a dialect coach on
this
and so then I he they said say things
like you've been here for a long time
so then I would say it and they're like
yeah that's it I go but I took the
accent off on that one like there was no
accident left
so after the ADR session I told all my
friends this movie is gonna suck because
they had messed with my accent so much I
was like no they're they're ruining it
the movie's gonna suck like don't watch
it I was like I was devastated after ADR
no
so and yeah so when you saw what they
had done what you'd put back into it
when you adr'd all this [__] you went
back did you go back in again when was
the first time you saw her did you go to
the premiere and going I don't know what
I'm gonna say
so were you doing what I did yeah were
you doing what I would do is telling
everybody look I'm sorry I'm probably
gonna suck on this I'm probably my
accent's terrible just don't judge me
you weren't thinking this was gonna do
it I'm gonna say my accent was terrible
and I'm like well yeah because they
messed with it they didn't let me do it
I wanted you know what's funny is I
remember I've seen it and I I honestly
I'm not saying this because you're here
I loved it
I loved it I really did I thought I
remember saying wow that's hilarious
she's hilarious oh my God I didn't think
unless you speak this language or you
most people don't the world they watch
and they just say oh they oh she has an
accent they don't think too much about
things I wasn't thinking where is she
from exactly I just was like oh this is
fun
so cool thank you I swear to God me I
dropped dead that's how I felt
when you saw the movie did you say wow
I'm part of something that's going to be
huge
um no
I didn't know like it was nobody knew it
was going to be huge
but
I mean there there were moments of
things happening around us where we
could see they were trying to
expand because my character was not
meant to be a main character I wasn't in
the original poster but they they I was
testing well and so they were expanding
my my presence
um and they were starting to include me
in a lot of the the
um magazine press and stuff that that
people were getting and
sorry my light is giving me something so
you were stealing the show in a lot of
ways I don't know about that whatever
but you know you were a likable
character was testing well and they kept
bringing you for and by the way you
probably got paid [__] for the movie The
First One
yeah do you remember going oh my God
this is what they're paying me no I I
didn't care they I would have done it
for free it was my first Studio film
so I was so happy to book a role in a
studio film like who cares about money
that's that's great that they're giving
me something for it
but then the second one comes and then
you're like okay you're like